let's go
my name is joe and i got to go cause i'm
on the flow and i'm on the show where my
job is i say yes or no
i remember like being eight and being
like one day i want to cut my hair like
like i think this is so cool i've always
loved it should have known i was gay not
that cutting your hair means that but i
just like should have known that i was
so obsessed with it and and finally i
got my mom on board i got my whole team
on board
and i was like i have to do it before
somebody says no so then i immediately
chopped it the next day 10 years of
impulse you know what i mean it was like
it was long but then fast
she's exclusive ladies and gentlemen
i am not single and i don't want to
mingle
no i'm a loyal lady we love rachel who i
did the podcast with um i am in a
relationship and i'm i'm very i'm very
happy i'm very lucky to be loved it's
been it's been very nice i think
something that's been great is
it's been so honest
and i i think that's a mistake that i've
made in the past is you know maybe just
like
trying to be something that i maybe
wasn't um
but but but this is just so pure and so
honest and it's so real
and it just feels so
it feels like i
like i slash we got it right the winner
of so you think you can dance could be
in this room right now what is happening
what what what
we got some tapping going on it is so
brilliant to watch these people perform
and dance and share their craft with us
i mean they are all
so different and so unique and it's so
magical to watch the stories that they
portray well on stage they're not
dancers they're artists i love being
honest and i love it for two reasons i
love being honest when it's it's hard
honesty but i love it when it's
love honesty because it means so much
more
when you are just truthful you know if
you if you give everyone a yes and
everyone a good job then they don't mean
as much but when you are true and honest
to what deserves it i mean it's it's so
fulfilling dance moms dancing with the
stars mass singer serious dance mod
revolution uh
so you think you can dance
america's got talent that's been out on
instagram six elimination shows have
been in this 18 year old's life that's
that's like almost one every other year
that's wild it's funny because after
every single elimination show i say i'm
never gonna do one again because there's
very stressful mentally physically all
the things um
but i just love it so much there's
something about the competitiveness but
also the family commodity i mean it's
just it's all amazing so i've never been
judged and so getting to be a judge is
so amazing on this show
i love dance i'm a sucker for it and i
can't help it but just enjoy it and so
the show is filled with that matthew is
so the emotional one always [ __ ] is the
hype one i'm the honest one
maybe twitch and i could go back and
forth between hype and honest i feel
like if it's a hip-hop he goes more hype
i go more honest
or if it needs to be like technical
he'll go more honest i'll get more hype
but if it's like if it's like
contemporary twitch goes hype i go
technical matthew's like the storyline
he's not british but we're gonna make
him british today it's like the story
behind that all right shuster so deep i
love dancing so much um my best friend
in the whole wide world his name is ezra
he was a contestant on season 16 so you
think he made top six
his he auditioned with a girl he oh i'm
not allowed to say any of this um
anyways him and i want to just perform
for fun on the show my mom said she's
like i can't wait to see who pukes i
can't wait to see them rolls their ankle
she's like i can't wait for all the
mishaps who's going to forget their
number who's going to stand there who's
going to blank um yeah cool i mean
listen at the end of the day we are also
creating a reality tv show and that is
bound to happen we are in i mean i'm not
in but the these these dancers are
immensely draining
areas of life right now and to be put on
this show
it can be tough um but you know that's
why we're here dance moms i messed up a
lot tour i used to fall all the time i
will always remember where i came from
and everyone had a different experience
with abby and a different experience
with dance moms i think entering the
show as a big fan i left the show still
a big fan and i you know obviously i'm
not a fan girl of the show but i really
respect the show and i respect what the
show did for the dance world and for you
know for me for maddie for kalani for
kendall for nia um for kenzie i respect
what it did for all of us um
abby abby actually taught me a lot you
know abby has a lot of dance knowledge
and and i i carry a lot of what she
taught me with me
um
yeah i i don't see her obviously as
often as i used to i mean i used to be
with her every single day
but i mean i wish her well if she if she
texts me i reply
[Music]
you